[Música]
Hola Bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de France 24 sobre el Éxodo los
saluda Julieth riaño
[Música]
Después de tres semanas a la espera de
un puerto seguro unos 230 migrantes
rescatados en aguas del mar Mediterráneo
desembarcaron en Francia fueron
encontrados por el barco humanitario
Ocean biking a la deriva frente a las
costas de Libia desde ese momento
comenzó la travesía por encontrar un
lugar para su desembarco Y ante la
negativa de Italia de permitirlo Francia
decidió hacerlo en total nueve países
participarán en su acogida este episodio
confirmó con hechos la política
restrictiva que el gobierno de Georgia
melón y prometió para el tema migratorio
lejos de cumplir con las obligaciones
que dicta el derecho internacional para
la acogida segura de migrantes
ante la posición radical de Italia
Francia advierte con consecuencias
el entendimiento entre Emmanuel macron y
Georgia meloni resultó efímero la causa
los migrantes en ruta por el
Mediterráneo Italia presionó a Francia
para que acogiera a unos 230 migrantes
rescatados en el mar un pedido que el
ministro del interior francés calificó
de irresponsable Francia respondió y
decidió entonces suspender su
participación en un acuerdo de reparto
de migrantes por lo que el país dejará
de acoger a 3.500 personas llegadas A
Italia a pesar de haberse comprometido
durante el verano a aceptarlas también
reforzará los controles fronterizos a
partir de ahora la respuesta desde el
gobierno italiano fue igual de enérgica
la reacción de Francia a la petición de
acoger a 234 migrantes cuando Italia ha
acogido a 90.000 soles este año es
totalmente incomprensible Italia
considera que ya cumplió con su cuota de
acogida de migrantes y acusa a sus
socios europeos de falta de solidaridad
sin embargo el derecho marítimo dice que
un barco en peligro debe ser rescatado
el estado que tiene jurisdicción sobre
la zona de búsqueda y rescate el Ocean
biking había recurrido inicialmente a
Malta luego a Italia pero fue ignorado
en junio una docena de países de la
Unión Europea adoptaron un acuerdo para
reducir la presión sobre las Naciones
mediterráneas que reciben a la mayoría
de los migrantes acordando repartir
10.000 de estos solicitantes de asilo
entre ellos por año pero desde que se
firmó el acuerdo sólo 164 migrantes han
sido reubicados desde Italia a otras
naciones del bloque
vemos que en realidad los países no
están convencidos Y además estos
mecanismos funcionan mal o no funcionan
en absoluto la solidaridad europea
tambalea sin que ninguna solución logre
imponerse desde la crisis de 2015
y mientras sigue la espera por una
solución comunitaria los países europeos
toman medidas para contener el ingreso
irregular de personas a sus países Reino
Unido y Francia firmaron un nuevo
acuerdo por más de 72 millones de euros
con el objetivo de frenar a las
embarcaciones de migrantes en el Canal
de la Mancha todo tras un aumento
constante en el flujo de personas que ya
supera las 40.000 en lo que va de 2022
ya es una realidad Reino Unido y Francia
unificarán sus esfuerzos para intentar
frenar la migración de indocumentados
tras cerrar un acuerdo por 72,2 millones
de euros Francia ayudará a bloquear el
paso de personas por el Canal de la
Mancha una fuente de tensiones entre
ambas naciones en el pasado
tenemos que reducir significativamente
el número de personas que cruzan el
canal el Primer Ministro ha sido muy
claro Yo he sido absolutamente Clara en
cuanto a la migración ilegal
Especialmente con las cifras que hemos
visto recientemente es totalmente
inaceptable
con el dinero del acuerdo Se espera que
Francia aumente en un 40% sus patrullas
en las playas de la frontera entre 2022
y 2023 y que los mismos policías
británicos también las puedan vigilar
todo con la más alta tecnología como
drones perros detectores o helicópteros
para desmantelar las redes de
Contrabando y sobre todo para impedir
que la gente pase
hay varios elementos en el acuerdo y
creo que representan un paso positivo en
nuestra colaboración con los franceses
no se va a arreglar de la noche a la
mañana no es una bala de plata creo que
por primera vez tenemos ventajas tanto
para los franceses como para Reino Unido
Y es que lo que va de año más de 40.000
migrantes han cruzado la frontera a
través del Canal de la Mancha en su
mayoría albaneses iraníes y afganos que
huyen de conflictos internos una cifra
muy por encima de los cerca de 28.500
del 2021 algo que ha ejercido presión
sobre el nuevo gobierno de richizunak no
obstante tras políticas como la
devolución en caliente de solicitantes
de asilo a Ruanda muchas organizaciones
de defensa de derechos humanos han
criticado la política migratoria de los
conservadores en Reino Unido mientras el
futuro de miles de personas en peligro
está en manos de políticos el tránsito
no para solo en 2021 en las rutas por el
Mediterráneo y el Atlántico occidental
más de 3.200 migrantes murieron o
desaparecieron tomaron el riesgo Pues en
casa ya no encontraban opciones
observa Patricia cuando las condiciones
de vida comenzaron a empeorar y la gente
empezó a luchar con Los costos de vida
mi primo decidió de repente emigrar
tenía tanta prisa Así que se fue como
muchas otras personas y tomó este camino
que es bien conocido aquí como el camino
de la muerte
En definitiva la acogida de unos cuantos
no soluciona el problema de fondo y no
son suficientes las buenas intenciones
ante una crisis humanitaria que necesita
una respuesta urgente y el dato de
migración de la semana
275,500 personas ingresaron de forma
irregular por las fronteras de la Unión
Europea Durante los primeros 10 meses de
2022 un 73% más que en el mismo periodo
del año anterior
hasta aquí migrantes de France 24 los
invitamos a comentar en nuestras redes
sociales con el hashtag migrantes f24
sigan con más información en France 24 y
France 24.com
[Música]